quelques siècles les sépare et pourtant
tu plais grande et ps noces ont un point
commun
les retrouvailles musiques et danses
traditionnelles bretonnes sur fond de
citer des années 90 dans ce quartier
populaire de rennes on appelle ça
l'interactivité que ça fait penser à une
manifestation sans aucune ségrégation
l'ouverture au niveau des styles
ouverture au niveau les gens je crois
que cette actualité c'est très important
important aussi de s'éloigner des grands
orchestres et du centre ville
ici la fête de la musique sort des
sentiers battus répondre aux besoins du
quartier et surtout décentraliser la
fête de la musique et se démarquer du
centre ville qui est plus musiques
actuelles rock pop voilà en bretagne on
ne sait si la fête passe avant ou après
la musique
une chose est sûre ça dure toujours
jusqu'au bout de la nuit